جبهه حرب جديده فتحت افواه السلاح في
السودان طرفها الحرب عسكريان كلاهما تمرس
في ميادين القتال بدرفورد اما وصفه الصداع
فمكوناتها تقتصر على وجود قوتين مسلحتين
داخل الدوله الواحده
مصير البلاد حاليا بات على راحتي من كان
من المفترض حمايته والقادم لا ينذر الا
بصيف حار سيثقل كاهل السودانيين مجددا بعد
ان عاشوا حروبا وانقلابات عده جلبت
الويلات لهم تاريخيا المره الاخيره التي
تقاتل فيها قائد عسكري ونائبه شرقي
افريقيا كان في جنوب السودان وقتل حينها
حوالي 400 الف شخص اما صراع اليوم فيزعزع
استقرار جارتها الشماليه وما يدور حاليا
فيه قد ينتهي فقط بفوز احدهم في المعركه
مع عدم استبعاد حرب اهليه طويله الامد قد
تجر جيرانها وفق صحيفه
على مدى السنوات الماضيه تشارك البرهان
واحمدت معارك عده معا يد واحده وقوه
مشتركه ففي عام 2021 اكد احمدتي لصحيفه ان
قوات الدعم السريع تدعم القوات المسلحه
السودانيه فيما اخبر البرهان الصحيفه
الغربيه انه بمجرد اكتمال الانتقال الى
الديمقراطيه سيعود القاده الى التكنات
وسيتم اجراء تصويت في عام 2023
وعود تبخرت مع اطلاق رصاصه الاولى منذ
اربعه ايام من العاصمه الخرطوم ليدخل
السودان ازمه خطيره ربما يمكن ان تحسم
صلحا او تتوسع وتاكل ما تبقى من البلاد
اياد حمود العربيه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات